hey guys welcome back to the evident
Catalan podcast the podcast where we are
dropping shocking truths such as how we
made at we may not actually be youtubers
we might be bloggers because really what
defines what you are what you've had
more success at what you're doing
started but also what you've been doing
for longer and what you've done more of
because today we're gonna be talking
about our secret blog that may not
actually be so secret because it's Evan
and Caitlin calm there's a lot of things
that you probably don't know about our
blog yes sorry I am um I'm all tied up
in knots here with my mic my headphones
those of you who are just listening may
be confused right now but Caitlin has
got herself into a fine mess okay I'm
good I was looking up data Caitlin yes
on Evan and Caitlin calm we have four
hundred and fifty-one total posts a
hundred and forty eight are from main
channel videos a hundred and eight are
from gaming videos which leaves a
hundred ninety five blog posts we have
done more blog posts than we have done
YouTube videos wait wait but don't we
have one for every podcast - meaning
there's like 59 oh yeah whatever 195 -
59 is oh we just passed it we just
recently passed our 136 blog post week
okay so we just recently became
youtubers lot of blog posts we had a lot
of blog posts and what you guys might
not have have heard from us yet because
we just haven't talked about it much is
when we talked about our our journey as
youtubers we kind of started it with
when I quit my job
we started Instagram we started making
products for what them
and to me that's kind of where I
initially thought we started but I was
wrong
it kind of started with the blog it kind
of started with the blog back in
February of 2013 that's more than seven
years ago and we didn't actually start
our Instagram until September of 2016
yeah well I think I think one reason why
we think of the start of like this whole
YouTube thing being that period of time
where you quit your job and we started
selling products is is because that's
when we started thinking of like what
what can we do as a job and that's why
we started the Instagram account because
social media Instagram was for business
reasons the blog wasn't for business
reasons but I will say I will say the
blog was one of those things where it
was like it's probably not ever gonna be
a I'm just doing it as a hobby but like
if one of our pin or if one of our posts
blows up on Pinterest I'm not gonna be
mad about it like if we get pingbacks
from other blogs featuring our projects
Pinterest I know I know like saying all
the times like I wouldn't have been
upset if somehow we fell into being
full-time bloggers at the time so a lot
of what we're gonna be talking about
today like we have so much to talk about
I don't know we're gonna be one
podcasters we those kind of chanced upon
this topic and I'm like we would then we
started thinking about it more and like
talking about things with each other and
really oh no no no we need to save this
all for the podcast because we were
getting really excited so I have a big
list Caitlyn has a big list but but I
kind of want to start with the beginning
because Caitlyn was the instigator for
the blog so I think I want to like I
want to hear the story from your
perspective like why did you start it
where were your inspirations what was
your like where did this come from so um
back when we were still in college and I
was shopping for my first
mint ice that's when I started getting
into like DIY blogs and home design
blogs and stuff like that because I was
looking for inspiration of things that I
could do on the cheap to make my
apartment that I didn't even have yet
look nice because that's what it was all
about them like cheap ways to hack the
system yeah it was like the prime of
like IKEA stuff like that you know like
things you could do without a ton of
tools or skills that you could do in a
small space and anyways I got super into
it and specifically I fell into two
blogs that like I I don't fully keep up
with their blogs anymore but I still
follow them both on Instagram and that
is young house love and chris loves
julia and like especially young house
love I do still keep up with him I
listen to their podcast yeah everything
so I've been following these people
since 20 mmm if I was looking at them in
college like it's been a while it's been
a while so um so yeah so I I followed
their blogs and it was just a big
inspiration to like not only to do
projects like they were doing but I just
thought the fact that they shared it was
really really cool and I wanted to do
that even though it adds a bunch of work
kind of unnecessarily because you know
it like I said I didn't really expect it
to be like the commenting so it's kind
of like a little bit of a hobby with
like but but maybe a hobby but with like
oh but if we could do this full-time it
would be really cool like a hobby with
that kind of like thing in the
background well I think I'm not sure
where to jump in with with this side
tangent so keep where you're at
bookmarked but I feel like it might be a
good point to kind of like share some of
our our past history because in a way
Kalyn and I realized that we have been
wanting to share things online since
like online existence online existed
yeah both of us have art accounts on
various websites where we shared art I
created multiple blogs one all about
games and one is so funny I basically
was like um
Meem aggregator but I find funny
pictures not to share them on my blog
and they are like mostly wholesome
things and cute things and cat things
and like a mix of like cats science and
wholesome content that's great
well and I want to cover in video games
oh yeah those are my two like websites
that I started and they're all kind of
what I do now is you know and I had two
before we started the Evan and Kaelyn
blog as well mine I was not nearly as
dedicated to them but I had one for like
recipes that I started there hosted like
five recipes and stuffing at five and
then one that when I was in my apartment
I started documenting my projects and it
was like 99% my DIY Halloween
decorations and then like a couple other
things yeah
Kalin's emo pass was still like
lingering dark Caitlin was still present
time she's still present but yeah but
like both of us have been both of us
have had inclinations to create content
and specifically share it online for the
longest time but for the longest time
there's not much point well even though
from like a Productivity standpoint
because also both of us like things to
have meaning to have purpose and it's
hard for us to do things long without
having that like understanding of why
we're doing and have that purpose and
everything yeah yeah and I think because
of that that's why the blog like we
would do it like very consistently for a
while and then we would fall off for
like six months and then we do it very
consistently for awhile but we did do it
from like 2013 to I think 2016 or 2017
where are our last posts before it just
now it we basically just use our website
as like a place to gather all of our
content from our videos and our gaming
stuff in our podcast and now a blog post
these days is just like a post with that
video embedded and any like links
associated like some of the videos used
to be we use it when we used to post
videos and
ride up a huge written tutorial let's do
the photos do plans diagrams additional
content would share that on like our
website and on reddit and on image rural
and on Instructables and just everywhere
we could share it and so there are some
of our blog posts and have a video and a
detailed write-up I have more than I
want to share on that outsourcing the
writing of that like stories around all
sorts of things but I feel like we're
not ready yet I feel like we need a yeah
background first we're gonna do things
in order and orderly manner probably not
yeah so inspiration you're inspired by
young house love chris loves julia
you had like some idea of like well
maybe it'll blow up i had hopes yeah
like um like i would do things like I
made a Pinterest account and post them
on Pinterest and things like that and I
got really into the technical ends of it
like from the beginning we had it set up
and the set up that we set up in 2016 is
still holding 2013 is still holding up
over seven years later you know we put
in analytics we put in like all of these
like like like a few different plugins
and we have like we have and updating it
and we have been maintaining it because
it's good to own that URL to have that
history for Google so when people are
googling us now or like all sorts of
things we own so many search results for
our like merch and for our FAQ and for
all sorts of things it's come in handy
doesn't even post on evident Caitlyn
calm since 2013 long time we own that
that SEO you know and also because we've
been not we haven't branched out much
with how we name our various things
evident Kalyan
Evan Kalyan gaming Evan and Caitlyn
Murch Evan and Caitlyn shop yep yeah I
think another thing that like I actively
thought about then and
in terms of like oh well in case this
does go out to more than just you know
our families yeah reading it is like the
voice that we wrote in and I think
that's something that like we've could
have carried through to our videos
Kailen Kailen wrote everything one of
our blog posts I wrote a few I'll give
you all the credit though and she was
hilarious she did like she did like
clickbait e titles but in a good way not
not clickbait but like there's a great
one that I actually still gets views
every now and then still galvanized to
pecs no blowtorch required you know it's
like why would they need a blowtorch for
plumbing things you know and that's an
early example of click plate and Kaitlyn
I want you to read
I took an extract from the galvanized to
pack snow blow to its required I want
you to read this is the intro just like
we do right now with skits okay you are
doing kind of like almost skit like
funny intros for our blogpost and I just
love it okay first before I look down
and read just to give you guys context
galvanized tippex this what this post
was is we have like galvanized plumbing
galvanized pipes in our house and we had
some leaky ones and so you're swapping
out some of them to PEX piping which is
a different like more modern type of
plumbing just so you have like I don't
know if that context is needed okay so
it's written it's it's written as a
conversation so I will do a normal voice
for one side of the conversation and
British accent for another okay
how do we spend our Saturday nights
these days why hanging out in our attic
for six and a half hours of course six
and a half hours Calum bloody hell why
on earth would you hang out in a blazing
Attic because six and a half plenty
hours Oh
imaginary British person person because
we were working on the PEX piping
project I mentioned in her last post of
course you're so silly
I thought you so you so confidently said
and I quote it didn't look and all that
hard or expensive to DIY your own pecs
yeah well the pecs part was easy
it's just everything else I took freakin
forever gosh don't get testy with me You
cheeky prat
don't be such a turd bullets
fish-and-chips thousand skip Kaelin you
just did a skit I did I did a skit and
right that's so great
oh man that's that's so crazy well like
like like even back then you were doing
like interesting titles feels funny yeah
you're doing interesting titles that are
like a little bit clip baby but like
also not because the reason why you said
no blowtorch required for that is
because in the middle of this project
Kailyn was looking up tutorials because
the PEX pipe or the the galvanize wasn't
coming undone because it was rusted and
they're like one click tip use your blow
torch to heat it up in our attic and our
wood attic that seems like a bad idea
wasn't really it wasn't really yeah so
it's interesting that like the
foundations that we thought of and had
in place in the way way back in the day
mm-hmm still held true I mean let me
look up this post this galvanized
2-packs was posted in 2013 April so
that's like at the very beginning of our
like sharing stuff online journey yeah
that is so interesting and I'm not sure
exactly why I wanted things to be funny
to like I think I had more fun with it
and I think like of the blogs I followed
young house love was one of the only
ones that was actually like there are
humorous parts in their writing and I
really enjoyed it
and I think that's why I wanted to do it
uh-huh
but I mean looking through these posts
my gosh they're so detailed
we almost share more information than
these no I we share information their
YouTube videos too because you know a
videos worth of bajillion words but like
my gosh this they were they were like
all these different steps there's a
bajillion photos there was diagrams that
Caitlin Mae
she-she like I would like illustrate
over photos and custom illustrations to
show steps yeah I guess you do drawing
should label things I labeled where the
mouse poop was the leaks and the mouse
poop but also you labeled the mouse from
there for a reason because if you see a
mouse poop there might be leaks that's
where the mountain I'm Isis go yeah
where there's leaks fun fact but it's so
interesting looking back to this cuz
like that's like at the very beginning
of when we started a blog and from the
beginning you did it with humor with
quality with polish with everything set
up future proofed and everything and
that's kind of like how we did our
YouTube videos yeah no that's true cuz
it was I mean our YouTube videos were
very similar because they were tutorials
but they were I mean we tried to like
throw in bits of humor yes okay just cuz
we just read a thing I had another thing
that I wanted to read that made me laugh
cuz very like kind of poking through our
blog and we're gonna talk I want to talk
about the feeling there's a poking
through the blog later - okay but just
to read another funny thing so a lot of
our blog posts also covered like a bunch
of our wedding projects so we would talk
about like the wedding a lot and I find
this particular excerpt funny because
like on our gaming channel this is like
a lot of backstory but on our gaming
channel one thing that we we say and the
like our chat says a lot is butts we say
the word bust a lot too but it which
stemmed from when like a lot of gaming
channels we're getting flagged as for
kids content which especially buying
crap especially minecraft which we play
a lot and you know people don't want it
to be tagged as for kids because then
you don't get targeted ads so you
basically make a lot less money and so
we're like we need to say say a bad word
but not so bad that we get demonetized
and so we just decided the word was
butts so our chat periodically would
just like start all shouting but anyways
a lot of people it confuses a lot of
people
so I decide to give like the backstory
here so I it was in a post that was
about like our upcoming projects and
to-do lists
item number one on the to-do list is to
get our butts married already
okay now I'm picturing just our butts
United in holy matrimony
do you kaitlin's but take evans but to
be your lawfully-wedded but husband for
as long as you both shall but it's great
I don't know I just like cracking myself
up very few people were reading these it
was very few well speaking of numbers
Caitlin I actually looked up some
interesting analytics so don't don't
look at my list because I have I have
this listed here but in total in the
past seven years what do you think the
total number of pages for our blog is oh
god sorry that that's kind of a very on
the spot I have no idea okay don't know
this isn't the easier question what do
you think the most viewed like like like
what do you think the most viewed post
is and how many views do you think it
has okay I know it is at least over
10,000 because I know we have at least
one thing that got pinned over 10,000
times yes I think you 50,000 I think you
might know what it is - what do you
think are most popular posts on our web
pages I'm gonna I'm gonna put it between
two it's either the part one of the love
letters or it's house buying for noobs
and just to give you guys context the
love letters that's the DIY marquee
letters we did a video on them - house
buying for noobs we wrote like a guide
for first-time home buyers after right
after we do you think it's one of those
- in about 50,000 views yeah it is both
of those are our top posts DIY mark a
making marquee letters number one house
buying for new boots number two marquee
letters is up to two hundred and forty
five thousand page views for it's like I
mean that's over seven years but that's
pretty good that's still pretty good
from a blog post from like yeah two
people and that was like one of our
first posts one of our first post that's
crazy
now some of that might have came from
like I think we might have linked it in
our YouTube video but most of it came
from organic well and when we post that
video that channel is pretty small yeah
and then how spying for noobs is up to
six sixty eight thousand views and in
total I mean those two took up a huge
chunk of it in total our blog has been
have pageviews of 1.4 million which is
so crazy to me because we put we put so
much time and effort and so many of
those views are also from our YouTube
channel and like just like a single one
of our videos has like way more than
that it's just yeah it's just crazy to
me oh my gosh but I like the house
binding for noobs that was really
interesting to like put ourselves in
that mind space again because we put so
much time effort research and everything
into that that blog post for what I I
still I'm not fully sure why but we put
like days of effort so much so much so
into this post and I think one of it one
of the reasons why is because like we
found that process confusing we learned
a lot and we wanted to share our
experiences and we felt strongly that
like we were in a good position to share
sure yeah like but also not just like we
were knowledgeable we wanted to share
what it was like for first-time
homebuyers yeah well because I had done
a bunch of research trying to find that
guide myself cuz there's a bunch of
guides but because they're written by
professionals they leave out a lot of
the like basic questions that I had yeah
it's almost like too high level or not
because it's real to high level and I
find a lot of the like really basic
stuff that I needed to know so we broke
it down at a much more basic level so
like we saw a gap I think like part of
it is I also kind of wanted to have it
for us for like this process cuz like
all the research was so painful and I
think another part of it is even though
like we're like just for fun like I
still kind
wanted things to get back yeah and that
did really well on Pinterest and
everything and we had some realtor
saying that they might use some of how
we explained it which are really cool
yeah and they're like as a realtor this
is accurate and explained simply and I'm
like wow that's just what we wanted that
makes us really happy to hear yeah it
was very satisfying it was helping
people but it was interesting that like
we put in so much effort so much effort
I don't know I think in some ways and we
didn't really have a clear reason okay
this is interesting so the number of
pageviews surprised you in a good way
like wow that's actually more than we
thought
one thing that's interesting we ran ads
on our website for not that long of a
period of time we we really didn't
monetize our website that much but we
did monetize it for over a year
guess how much money we made five
hundred dollars a hundred and fourteen
dollars we put days weeks months of
effort we put so much time into this
blog oh we made a hundred and fourteen
dollars that's that's so pain did
monetize it in any other way we tried
once actually no cuz it wasn't really
monetized but we did try to do a partner
to post once what was that but it was
more like to hopefully get views cuz
they weren't gonna pay us that sounds so
scummy I know I know
but it was like the first time a company
had reached out and it was this I'm not
gonna say what company it was but it was
like a relatively like medium to
high-end furniture company and they were
promoting their couches and so they had
this thing where they were like oh make
a mood board you know if you make a mood
board and you include our couch in your
mood board and you and you link to it
then we'll we'll share your post on our
social media which like no those are me
but just like archive I don't even think
that they did it I don't think they did
either because like scam I I followed up
with them several times like weeks went
by and then finally and
we had already published the post
because they were like we'll publish it
and then our team will review it and
decide if they want to do it and then
they came back to us with like edits and
I was just like no I just stopped I
didn't respond after that because it had
been weeks and I've really exposure into
like things that you need to be aware of
let me get into this I think that we did
go in with like a little more eyes open
mm-hmm
I mean that's just one very small
experience but one very small experience
but still yeah but that's crazy and we
still don't have abs on the website just
because like we don't get that many
views on it it's like not worth passing
the people who actually go there for
like not much money yeah plus it's like
you know if they go there and they click
on a YouTube video the YouTube video has
ads so that's you know that's the best
way yeah oh that's so weird
yeah so weird so so we talked about your
inspirations I want to kind of talk
about like ask you what were your
thought process behind how you added
humor cuz you had a lot of fun humor
Kaitlyn added gifs
she told funny stories she had a great
voice like what were your some of your
thoughts behind why you did it and how
you did it yeah well I mean we kind of
touched on this lightly but I think it
was just like I wanted our blog to be
unique because there were a lot of very
very like so polished so nice DIY blogs
where like the pictures were perfect and
it was picture-perfect families our
pictures were not that perfect our
pictures were terrible and I just felt
like if we were gonna lean into
something our strong point was not gonna
be having beautifully staged photo haha
our strong point was gonna be like the
voice that we told things and and I also
just like riding blog post is a lot of
work and I had more fun if I could make
myself chuckle um yeah so I did do
things like I added gifs somewhere like
we would make our own gifs and then some
were like just you know a little Mimi
type things that I found I would try to
do like little fun cute
illustrations oh you know you know Kayla
did so much custom art for our blog and
everything like that she did the whole
illustrated guide on how to like fold
the marquee sign and like weird oh yeah
and color-coded everything and yeah my
gosh so many illustrations cuz like I
really wanted it to be like like
visually nice and visually clear but I
would also try to add like humor in
those illustrations and stuff like
sometimes I'd have little characters of
goo or me or stuff like that jube was
definitely a character even back in the
blog days we were just scrolling through
and there's so many joob photos also our
very first one oh and I was looking up
when we started the art Instagram I
didn't want to scroll all the way back
to our Instagram so I actually searched
on our blog and we made a blog post
about starting Instagram and that's why
I found it and I was looking when we
first posted it we had 49 followers and
six posts and the very first post was
mochi and the 49 followers were probably
just like our friends oh man
yeah that's that's so crazy but yeah I
for for humor I think it was just like
wanting to kind of be unique because I
knew perfection wasn't wasn't the right
thing to aim for and I feel like that
still kind of holds true and our YouTube
videos like we're not making like the
most absolutely breathtaking
like gorgeous pieces of furniture or art
and we just try to lean in to like being
ourselves and like making bad jokes and
having fun but yeah so it's interesting
that there's like that through line
between between them yeah so what was
your most memorable post that you made
there like you remember I think I
remember I think I think I might predict
is it the poopy water my first foray
into creative storytelling I think that
you might have already told this story
on it
your podcast I think I have a quick
summary is basically we had some
plumbing issues after some people
working on the house had no mercy on our
toilet and I had a very traumatizing and
then we left on vacation then we left on
vacation and it was there and we came
back to it Oh God oh gosh Oh Josh
it was truly traumatizing and I felt
like I had to write about it in detail
on the blog with drips with just lots of
gifs well I got very creative with like
gifs because I didn't I did not actually
take any photos or video process I had
to endure i'm kahlan was freelancing at
the time and I was at at work yeah so it
was just Caitlyn soloing it man so that
reminds me of um one reason that I think
another reason that that I think we did
the blog goes back to you know how you
were just saying like we like things to
have purpose yeah um so some of the
projects we did a lot of them we saved
money by doing things ourselves I truly
do think there are some things that like
really wouldn't have cost us that much
to have a professional come do and we
still did it anyway and I kind of felt
like having a blog to post projects to
justified my cheapness hahaha cuz I'm
the cheaper I know how like I don't want
to spend money on stuff so I think that
might have been part of it too oh my
gosh Kalyn do you remember our shower
saga oh oh gosh oh gosh what the shower
saga is one more then after so much work
we hired someone and then it's still
terrible to this day well terrible to
this day bad okay Kimmy can you
summarize the shower saga cuz I feel
like then guys there's so much content
there's so many stories there's so many
things that I'm like I'm kind of wish
that we were like vlogging back then
yeah vlogging back then it was the blog
is more of a vlog style it is more vlog
yeah there is tutorial mixed with love
like life storytelling yeah yeah yeah
was tutorial and a lot of these were
multi-part posts like part 1 part 2 part
3
you know Atticus thing was ten parts it
was oh my gosh but the shower I don't
remember how many parts the shower was
but it was like so many things we had a
loose tile which so it kind of started
with that and we had to like take off a
tile and replace the tile and I think we
huh you took it off and we hired someone
to replace it and then the thing that
took longer though was like our like
people had used caulk where they should
have used grout in parts of our shower
and so it was all like peeling off but
it was stuck in grout that was
underneath caulk was I spent days three
days days scraping it like way to
multiple tools I also went through
multiple seasons of the office I would
just had it on in the background
constantly so I associate just like
sitting in the shower scraping the walls
and the floor with the office you you
use like a screwdriver that we still
have we still have it is a round novel
it's like there's like there used to be
a screwdriver with sharp all sharp
corners yeah used to be a flathead
screwdriver it's like we have a
screwdriver there's just like a nub the
caitlin hand filed down using grout in a
heart in our Schaffer um you went
through like an entire razor blade or
that down to another multiple razor
blade multiple razor blades and you went
through an entire like scraper tool like
a paint tool or something like that I
don't know like how many like imagine
sanding metal down multiple times using
a shower yeah yeah I wasn't scraping
grout away with tools I was making tools
away with grout from days I was in there
and then finally even my cheapness
couldn't take it anymore and I was like
we have to hire someone to fix the
shower situation and haman did they did
sanded grout or they sanded caulk where
I had scraped away all the caulk and I
guess I was partially better then the
normal clock that had been there but
guess what's now peeling
and we're in the same situation is that
all sanded caught yep yep and it's uh
only lasted it was only fixed for like
three months yeah
so upset that like I went through so
much work and someone to basically undo
my wife even as di wires who do DIY as
their job there are problems in our
house which we just ignore what we've
been ignoring it for years now I don't
want to hire someone else to come back
and do it because I'm traumatized haha
and we're not gonna do it ourselves
correct Rama tires yeah but the blog
going through a pose did bring back so
many memories of just like I mean a lot
of the projects we were doing we're just
like not super exciting home stuff you
know that's kind of where we started
hmm it wasn't like doing artistic resin
project so we did have a couple art
things in there yeah you like fun DIY
like Halloween yeah tutorial things but
yeah so much it was like like patching
or exterior siding and fixing leaks hey
our exterior siding is still doing good
good solid solid well I mean we could
just tell stories for so long about all
of our past DIY projects yeah like um
things that went wrong we can do a whole
podcast about like DIY has gone wrong
have we done that I think we did do that
okay if you if you consider that we
started the blog in 2013 we've been
putting out content like especially
project related content for a long time
so I feel like it's justified that we
forget what we've done yeah that is
interesting that is interesting because
yeah we have been putting out content
for seven years we're og baby so over so
og we're just so og we forget how og we
are just we were completely unsuccessful
for for at least three years or four F
for those yeah yeah three or four years
yeah you know we were learning Caitlyn
we are incubating yeah but what was it
like scrolling through all of our like
old posts and everything and seeing all
of that again it was very nostalgic it
also made me simultaneously look forward
to like starting fresh with a new house
again and also dread starting fresh with
a new oh yeah we looked at some before
and afters of our house ooh
this house was bad I forget how unco Zee
and bad it was a fixer-upper it was a
fixer-upper yeah yeah yeah uh you know
it wasn't the worst but it was just it
had good bones had good bones some
renovations had already been done some
very poorly yeah but some had been
redone they I mean there's some things
that we are just fixing right now like
side update I got this really cool
little tool I'll link it down below so
lets you adjust doors up and down we
have had the door the door into our
bedroom
hasn't closed for seven years yeah I
just fixed that like oh yeah there's
yeah so there's still things on our
to-do list oh and we would post like
occasional upcoming project to-do lists
on the blog and some of them I'm like
wow we finally did that like changing
out the sconces by our front door yeah
and like painting the front room was
like yeah we finally did that and then
some were like uh like painting the
exterior of the house and I was like hey
like you know one of our very first post
that was kicked one of Kahless main
goals we're like okay this house is fine
but I don't like it's ugly outdoor paint
color and now it's kind of cozy right
your swarm you get warm oh yeah what
what feelings did you have scrolling
through the old posts kind of nah wasted
potential
but like ah so much work that liked it
so much work that
and then it got us somewhere I mean we
can't really separate evident Caitlyn
the blog from us now because we found
our voice we found how to document
basically there is a pretty smooth
transition between our blog post and our
very first videos if you think about it
because what we did is we planned out
the project we wrote the script which
was basically writing a blog post mm-hmm
we would write the intro we would write
everything that we wanted to say and
that has very strong ties to our blog
yeah that's true
and then we would just instead of taking
pictures while we did it we would film
well did it and that did there was an
adjustment period between like that and
you know we didn't need to do all of
that work to like bridge that gap but I
mean I do think that without the blog
there wouldn't have been the YouTube
channel I think another big thing just
taking it back even further is our
channel was based on like the concept we
had already developed in the blog which
was like oh dude doing DIY home
tutorials as a couple with like
hopefully kind of a you know funny some
funny undertones like a funny voice and
if we hadn't done the blog I don't think
we would have even thought to do a
YouTube channel because like without
that concept like what would we have
done I don't know but yeah I don't
probably would have just started like
vlogging randomly yeah I think that like
this this may come across as I don't
know I'm just gonna say it and this hope
it comes out okay but when when we were
writing the blog we were proud of it you
know I thought that Caitlyn's posts were
hilarious I always looked forward to the
things that she wrote and hopefully you
looked forward to the things that I
wrote we were proud of what we were
doing and we were getting very little
views yeah you know and we were like you
know what we have a wider unfound
audience and I think that like I'm not
sure like cuz looking back and when we
started our you
channel I think that like I'm like why
did we have so much confidence that we
could do this I don't know because it's
hard yeah I don't know why from the
get-go we were already like telling our
co-workers in our family like yeah we're
starting a YouTube channel and and I
think that we had confidence that we can
make it work well yeah we can do this
and looking back I don't I don't know
why we thought we had that much
confidence but like thinking about the
blog I think that's the reason why we
had the confidence even though we may
not have we might not have realized it
but we were writing blog posts that we
were proud of and that we thought were
good funny interesting well-written
informative all that stuff and yet they
weren't getting views and maybe that's
why we're thinking like okay maybe
YouTube is the place where we can grow
mm-hmm and express that's right
yeah and I never thought that back then
and I'm only thinking of it now
yeah but it rings true to me because I
thought eyes why wouldn't we just like
double down on the blog I think it's
because later we felt like there is
potential but it wasn't honestly also
people honestly like fixer-upper
fixer-upper fixer-upper gave us a lot of
confidence we like we're like this is
doing well we have vibes like this a
little bit like a couple not taking
themselves too seriously well but also
houses behind this team's wall we were
documenting ourselves through pictures
and like you know writing things we were
having fun we were joking around and one
of the big reasons why we did the blog
for so long is because it was fun for
the two of us to do and we're like
there's some genuineness there that
isn't even being captured in the blog we
saw fixer-upper we're like we can do
that we have energy similar to that that
isn't being shown yeah you know there's
a larger capture that in photos mm-hmm
yeah that's so interesting to see how
like the mindset we were in but that was
around the time when when fixer-upper
was starting to get popular yeah yeah
that's so weird to think about so weird
oh man sorry I think that I think that
this might be a good place to pause
yeah because I definitely want to get
into like versus you too yeah yeah
pairing the two contrasting experiences
and all this different stuff yeah
there's still more that I want to talk
about but we're already getting pretty
deep yes already getting pretty deep so
um we're gonna move on to thing with the
week but make sure you're you've done
all the things I don't know where you're
listening to this or how but hopefully
you're probably subscribed so we'll look
forward to resuming then but first we
want to hit on something of the weeks um
and my thing of the week is minecraft
shaders I know this is a little bit
nerdy this is like getting off a little
bit of the weed I feel like that applies
to like 90% of your thing of the week's
yes but for those of you who may not be
playing may not know about minecraft
it's one of the biggest games in the
world is one of the most popular games
in the world and most people play it
just like the basic version but I have
been finding a lot of fun trying out all
different sorts of shaders because it
improves the graphics a lot and honestly
when I'm playing it with shaders on it
just makes me kind of happy and what
shaders are is they add fancy sky and
clouds and they add a Sun and they add
better shadows and they do all these
things like one thing that you might not
even know about Caitlin is in Minecraft
the grass block has a texture and if you
have a ton of grass blocks
it's the repeated texture the one thing
shaders and all these advanced things
does is it randomizes the orientation of
the blocks and the difference between
the same pattern repeated verse the same
pattern rotated is a lot more than you
would think that's crazy that's so cool
but also purposely not looking at it too
much because I wanted to be like kind of
a surprise when we start playing with
also shaders sometimes get a bad
reputation because they're too much and
when I first started getting into
shaders I thought wow that's too much
the sun is shining too much the torches
are like too fuzzy there's all these
things that I also didn't like and I
have been continually messing with them
and trying to find the right balance
between improvements and taking it to
far from the original minecraft so
messing with like when when light is
emitting from a source there's an aura
around and how much on that or do you
keep or not or you turn the whole thing
off how much of the rays from the Sun do
you keep and the lens flare I've just
turned so many things off completely
and tuned down so many more things cuz
like we've been talking you know I've
been mentioning it and I've seen
comments whenever I mentioned it some
people are like ooh shaders yay some
people like oh no I don't know about
shaders because it can be off-putting
and it can make it hard to see we're
hard to understand where you're just
like in a Michael Bay movie where
there's just like lens flares everything
and you walk outside it's so bright you
can't see and there's all these things
and everything yeah so it's been really
interesting kind of refining and
figuring that journey out I don't know
what's your favorite shader pack I know
my favorite shader pack right now is BSL
shaders I'll link it below and
everything and I also have been trying
to like get give back to the community I
know that like in our gaming streams you
know we try to encourage good deeds and
everything and I figure if I am going to
be using these resources you know it's
not we've been supporting some of them
on patreon and donating some cuz like
look we're gonna be using these things
and we want to give back and yeah we're
into sharing good deeds so we want to
support people who who put an extra time
to create these cool resources yeah yeah
okay I know what you think of the week
my thing of the week is a new podcast
mm-hmm which are so valuable that know
valuable okay it started um late last
year and I found it because it was
advertised on the ologies podcast which
is another one that I've um recommended
here before I believe and the podcast is
called scared to death and it's a scary
stories pot it's like by the way one of
Caitlyn's favorite things
she's been like reading no sleep for
years which is a subreddit anyway so ya
know sleep is a subreddit with scary
stories
this is like no sleep in podcast form
but one thing that makes it really
unique that I like is it's a couple a
husband and wife couple that that do
these podcasts together and
they have like a very fun rapport
they're often teasing each other and
just like giving each other a hard time
like the guy is like very much into the
creepy stuff and like doesn't get scared
as easily but like really is into it and
the girl is like kind of superstitious
about things and like the stories will
keep her up at night but she still
really likes them but she also hates
them you know that's a great combo and
so it's really funny to hear they're
back and forth and they do like a couple
stories and the podcasts will be things
that he's found online or like gathered
from books or whatever and a couple
stories of the podcast will be user
submitted or listener submitted stories
that she will read to him so you can
have a mix you have a chance for each of
them to like have genuine reactions
stories listener submitted stories ya
listener submit scary stories which
makes me want to do that I'm like oh I
don't know the best way to do it but
look in the description I think by the
time this is out we'll have some way for
y'all to submit stories
it'd be so fun we want to do a lot of
things like where we like interact with
you so maybe like a like advice column
with evidence evident Katelyn advice
column ask E&K then maybe a scary
stories sorry like submit embarrassing
stories like TI fu today I messed up I
think that would be super fun to get to
share like user-submitted store viewers
submit it's always fun listeners maybe
I'll create a like specialized contact
form on our website
avidin Katelyn comm slash podcast or
something no don't you don't listen to
anything I do what I do it out of the
link is I think that sounds so fine
it'll be fun to like interact with you
guys more in there yeah yeah super fun
podcast um it's not safe for kids they
do curse but like they're just really
funny and the stories are good if you
like scary stories so yeah alright well
guys thank you so much for tuning in and
listening by the way like sometimes when
I need a little pick-me-up I do go over
to like our Evan and Caitlyn podcast
review section
the Apple podcast it's so awesome and it
makes me happy so we do read those
reviews it means a lot to us so and it
helps other people discover the podcast
I'm not really sure what other people
would think if they like discover this
podcast they're gonna be like this is
weird who are these people but um
anyways reading your reviews makes us
happy so we appreciate it and we hope
you're having a great day and look
forward to seeing you in the next
podcast
[Music]